[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
let's go
we're gonna freaking do this right now
dude yeah a lot of naysayers out there
in the United States of American nay
worldwide even within the ranks of the
foot soldiers said leftovers is
not gonna do three weeks in a row that's
crazy well yeah and like uh yesterday
everyone was like covid scare what
there's no shot they're gonna come in
the studio and we wrong we looked you
dead in the eye and said you for
even thinking that about us yeah
leftovers is is we're doing it every
goddamn we we're doing the thing we're
doing the damn thing ladies and
gentlemen are all domestic terrorists
[Applause]
dude I feel like you always have diary
yeah that's an Ethan I don't always have
diary you literally always have diarrhea
what do you know about my
habits what do you mean we talk about it
you literally get up during the show
sometimes to engage in them to but
not to diarrhea bro okay okay so so well
yeah I happen to also have had diarrhea
last night I know we were talking about
we were talking about it before we
started
um yeah I I had some kind of like
stomach virus or maybe food poisoning uh
and I thought I was dying it was like I
actually took a day off on Monday as a
matter of fact oh yeah I knew you were
sick yeah so that's how you know that's
how you know she was super serious right
um you know better
I feel a lot better now I uh
I basically I I was like rain or shine
doesn't matter how bad my situation is I
will absolutely
yeah well I gave Hassan the choice I
said look we had a little bit of a coven
scare
it's up to you we're down and I said
covid that's fake brother and real dude
that's not even a real thing to me
brother hell yeah but you know the we're
doing this in the in the matter of the
public uh Public public interest yeah
absolutely do this for the public
because
yesterday was the big first uh debate
amongst the GOP hopefuls
um and also today
our boy
the one and only D Trump yeah Donald J
Trump baby live feed right now is about
to get his uh shot out oh wow there's an
actual crowd this time that's right
finally so we're this is outside Georgia
Courthouse yeah and the fake news media
doesn't want you to know about the crowd
because this is a live feed but I had to
rewind it because right now they decided
this gate was more interesting wow
typical news 18 nonsense you know what
I'm saying what are they cooking up over
there oh wow look at that this gate is
boring okay it's boring
we want to see our beautiful Patriots
out there in Georgia
so um unfortunately he was originally
meant to be uh brought in in the morning
but now it's not till like what three
three p.m which is
hell yeah good for me 3 P.M our
time good it's good for me they did that
for me thank you thank you funny Willis
shout out to my girl you know free slime
what's up do you think Trump is gonna
smile do you think he's gonna do a
thumbs up because I don't think you can
do a thumbs up they don't let you though
I was like give him one of these because
like Rudy Giuliani looked like such he
looks so pathetic and defeated and I
don't think that Trump's not going to
want to do that he should at least smile
I've been doing I've been doing face
psychology off of like the mug shots
that I've seen looking at who's gonna
flip
off of like their behavior during the
the mug shots and let me tell you
something okay Jenna Ellis smiling ear
to ear she's flipping Sydney Powell
looks a little crazy which is normal
she's usually very crazy I think she's
slipping too really there's a smile she
cracked like a like a little bit of a
smile
hold on I had the wrong dock open I'm
trying to open uh The Leftovers dock so
I can pull those up yeah I I think we
swapped computers today didn't we I got
this Dell dude I don't know why Dan
thought it was appropriate to give me a
Dell you bought it
not for me not you personally I haven't
seen this computer anymore it was like a
teddy fresh laptop that was just laying
around oh
I got a Dell remember how that used to
be like a brag now it's like a complaint
dude I got a freaking Dell
is it I have no opinion on that I didn't
know I didn't know it was like that I
don't know it's just a funny thing Dell
I mean who buys Dells anymore
you the only Dell I buy is Del Taco
diarrhea
diarrhea all day dude oh God I don't
even want to think about that all right
here's here's Rudy uh ghouliani
um mug shot
let's take a look here
511 there's no shot
dude that means he was like at least six
one before his like neck started sinking
into his chest there's no way that man
is 511 he's like 5'3
maybe even smaller but do you see what
I'm saying like Trump if he comes out
like this
isn't a good vibe the lighting is not
good no
excuse me here's what I think I think
some bold Patriots are going to make
sure that the photograph taken of Donald
Trump
is is
immaculate
you think the officers are Maga
yeah 87 of police officers in 2016 said
they voted for Donald Trump so they're
gonna hook him up with good lighting
they're gonna bring in the ring light
he's the he's the most uh
he is the most police loving president
of all time he's defended the police so
much I think that would be freaking
awesome if he these guys all look just
sad pathetic and then Trump comes in
like hmm
thumbs up Mr President salute please
yeah I could yeah oh yeah he's just
smoking
yeah pack watch hey except ultimately
regardless of how he looks on the mug
shot
this is the case he's got a case you
know what I mean he this is gonna be
a tough nut to crack
he's gonna have a little bit of a hard
time I suspect shut up with the Georgia
case yeah oh yeah it's serious business
I mean it's hard to get around a phone
call where you're like hey can you rig
this election for me literally like hey
can you just add votes out of the nether
for me okay that who amongst us has not
asked for you know 11 780 votes one more
than we need one more than we have I do
it all the time on on in our Google
polls man yeah for example I said should
I go to the Streamys I said yo I need 11
671 votes here
this is Trump this is uh what the mega
Trump photos are gonna look like are
they gasify him like yes dude oh my God
even even yesified Rudy still looks
cooked off like there's just some
there's a stink about him yeah oh God I
hate him so much look that's the face
you make when you get when you get hit
with the RICO that's the RICO face yeah
oh really real quickly at the top and
we'll move on but everyone watching
teddyfresh.com the tricks he dropped
just came out just dropped uh we did a
collab with Trixie all kinds of cool
stuff here uh Hassan let me know
uh if there's anything obviously it's
pretty specific at this point I feel
like every single most of my clothes in
my in my closet are are Petty fresh oh
yeah boy let's do it oh this
stuff's going fast what the f
the stockings and bag already sold out
and one of these shirts that's crazy it
just came out
oh this one too the hill all right well
I guess if you want something get over
there
uh but we're just sold out just in a
little uh announcement there all right
so let's let's go down the line here we
got so much to talk about
yeah so Trump's turning himself in in
Fulton County 3 P.M the deadlines on
Friday but he's doing it today some
speculate it's to suck any you know
attention from the debate onto himself
which is smart and very trump-like yeah
um Trump has agreed to a 200 000 Bond
like who cares uh certain conditions
including limits on social media about
the case
now this is I personally want as a fan
of Donald Trump's social media presence
and as a fan of a little thing called
the United States Constitution Freedom
specifically the First Amendment
have some or even worrying anymore in
the words of coconuts it's not it's not
they have made it completely illegal to
speak absolutely they've made it illegal
to say things
the sniffing is getting a little
familiar she's I don't know what she's
doing she's on the green screen girl no
she won't pee but I I I'm so scared that
she went back there and pooped or
something a poop is oddly uh usually
easier to clean than up yes yeah she's
got if she's having good BMS yeah no she
she don't she don't piss indoors yeah so
uh free speech is dead you were saying
yeah free speech is dead uh Sebastian
Gorka was right when he said uh this is
no different than uh ordering vanilla
ice cream
and he's right I tried ordering vanilla
ice cream and they indicted me literally
last week did everything right I got
vanilla ice cream and they had died
up can't can't tweet no more
can't say Mike Pence looks like a a
yesified version of as a Hutchinson any
longer I tried tweeting that out they
were like are you sure Twitter said are
you sure you want to tweet this because
you will go to jail yeah it's really
up so with this uh stipulation on
limits of social media talking about the
case if he does do that which like how
will he not violate that does that mean
he goes to jail because that's usually
what it means when you're out on bond
um yes which is going to be interesting
because
I don't know how they can enforce that
gag order in any capacity right because
Donald Trump
is a very unique person he he is the
former president of the United States
some might say the current president of
the United States Shadow president I
would say uh and by some I mean me I I
say that all the time you think he's
telling me I'm wrong but you know what
does he know no dude Trump is President
yeah okay good finally we both see the
light here
um
and
the really funny very quirky uh specific
of this uh of this particular instance
is that
he has to have Secret Service agents go
with him to prison yeah or jail super
interesting which is
I it's never happened it's kind of if
you it's really like the RICO where if
you think about the movies where the
Mobsters go to jail they have their
whole Posse there and they're cooking
like pasta sauce yeah that'll be him
yeah it'll be straight up like a mafia
jail except they're not like Goodfellas
paid yeah by the state law enforcement
officers you know what I mean which is
yeah it's a dub it's an extra dub I do
love it because it's like that is a
sitcom in the making that is a beautiful
TV show in the making sure whether it's
an animated TV series I'm calling the
rights on it when the strikes are over
okay
actually I'm taking advantage of the wga
strikes guess what I'm not I'm not Union
I'm writing that script uh Ted sarandos
hit me up is it Ted serendos
uh Netflix guy whichever one oh yeah Ted
yeah yeah something yeah yeah I'm
writing that I'm writing that script you
know hit my line see I'm scabbing you
you got it all wrong what you got to do
is just bypass the writers all together
and make a reality show about it yeah oh
just put cameras
how about like a Rudy Giuliani reality
show Rudy Giuliana Juliana it's called
bring those tits over here
those are my tits so let's take a look
at the mugshots we got ghouli I keep
saying this man is the Penguin but
nobody laughs when I say that but I
think it's no it's because it's you know
what it is it's because it's too real
like he he literally is the Penguin it
literally dragged his ass out of the
sewer with the raw fish in his mouth
yeah he is the Penguin uh Sydney Powell
also looking
horrible insane just coolish and
psychotic both she looks
so crazy and she is I and she is so
crazy and you can definitely tell and
then but but there's like a there's like
a slight like I'm gonna over Trump
behind those eyes I feel like maybe I'm
wrong but I'm getting a subtle hint of
like you know
when you smile on that mug shot you're
flipping that's why that's my take I
always thought of her as a true Soul as
they say uh Baldur's gay three man I
don't know maybe maybe this is your
moment when she when push comes to shove
and she realizes that she's gonna be the
one that's like being thrown out
China Elias crushing it already 100
flipped like that that's a state's
witness right there that is
that's that classic States stay witness
smile that's that like she's gonna make
gonna look like uh a steel trap that
never revealed any information about YSL
this guy Kenneth cheese bro
looking like zorg from The Fifth Element
with that black comb over
it's a weird comb over in it
he looks hot John Eastman looks insane
yeah I love that the more sex offenders
list photos dude the more the more white
they get like the more the exposure
can't over correct itself and it just
looks so blown out there's a lady in
there that's just like when you look at
it it's like a flashbang warning
at a certain point isn't it actually a
problem like for the the uh for the jail
like these are not useful mug shots I
don't know this is a horrible photograph
honestly it's this is straight up racist
like they're like if you're if you're
past a certain point of white like we
are so not used to arresting you even if
you do a crime that like the camera
exposure is not uh oh my God I felt my
mind but I was afraid to say it I think
I would have said it in a way that was
more offensive than what you did
thank you that's actually so
true though son yeah they're like
they're like nobody this white is ever
arrested in in Georgia
even if they are doing the most heinous
okay they're like why we just let
him go why is the game so crazy right
now we just white balanced it and it's
just like a like a tan yeah paper we
just white balanced it
yeah you can't get past this point of
white which I wonder what Trump's
almost purple like uh orange tan
I don't know what that's gonna look like
on here he'll look beautiful he'll get
nice and orange I'm not even kidding I
oh I'm almost this one the cat they laid
them on is insane
you can't even see her
like what is happening why are their
cameras not better man like this is you
know 4K
cameras are probably like a few hundred
bucks that's right Ethan you brought up
a really good point it's because we've
defunded the police
once again especially one yeah we've
defaulted the police we've defunded our
jails okay God these all look like sex
offender website photos man
this man just moved into your
neighborhood yeah
he has to knock on every door oh this
guy oh that's a serial killer I don't
give a shot that's a serial killer Ray
Smith who I I'm alleging and joking
because I don't know but this guy
kids dude Ray Smith looks like he's not
turning okay Ray Smith looks like he was
actually brought on but he's gonna like
try to assassinate a jury member during
the trial or something that's I think
this is witness tampering just this
photo alone yeah yo he looks like the
bad guy from Ghostbusters too Vigo bro
you're all over you were
what's happening you're deep in the
pocket with these references yeah today
hold on yeah no let me pull it up pull
it up Dan because I can't type on this
laptop okay this dumbass Dell yeah that
laptop keyboard is weird from from
Ghostbusters to my dudes he's the goo
Master do Master right here you gotta
see the full picture in the Discord
let's see
there you go okay here's here's vegan
that's it that's the face and here hold
on I gotta switch back and forth between
them
whoa great movie by the way Ghostbusters
2 yeah I have not seen it I don't watch
that whoa I don't watch that woke
liberal nonsense it's better than one in
my opinion no oh wow all right
Ghostbusters with women no no thank you
oh we're not talking about the woke one
dude he just they just had a
receptionist I didn't even think there
was like
women the women Ghostbusters there was
another
and that's there's another ghost
yeah I don't know I haven't watched it
in the past it's a great one I haven't
watched a single one of the Ghostbusters
okay but yeah he's Vigo he is the the
demon from Ghostbusters too thank you
what the hell bro yeah I'm not I have
not seen it I'll just I'll just say this
about David Shaffer he for sure has
hidden folders on his desktop somewhere
dude he looks like he never mind I'm not
gonna say it go on we've got the button
no no no it was gonna it was gonna come
across fat shamey that's why
okay he looks so pleasant and and and
plump and and Ollie he's a happy fat man
no hey guess what flipping okay yeah
they dropped they did the classic like
oh hey you want some coffee and donuts
and immediately he was like oh yeah
please
um give give them to me I'm I'm going to
tell you everything he hasn't heard
Oliver's new song about fat people
hitting those fudge rounds yeah buddy he
didn't but luckily he's not getting it
with the EBT so oh he might after after
his prison stint but so there they are
uh well done to them all and we look
forward to welcoming Trump into the fold
there fantastic
uh Rudy actually okay
tell me what you think of this Giuliani
was photographed outside a Bale
house yeah he's broke means he is so
broke he needed to alone to pay
his bail get your money up not your
funny up he put up his penthouse
in the Upper East Side uh in a building
well yes and no the building uh I
believe I looked at it I looked at it
because like I I was legitimately like
what if I bought this
dude that is really expensive so no
well technically not really you know no
they're not it's one of those like big
ass Barbers like a private elevator I
think but it's actually like the other
ones in the same apartment that are
remodeled went for like 2.7 million
really he's trying to sell his for 6.5
million
and can we pull it up on Zillow I'm
curious what it looks like yeah I if you
Google like uh find it if you Google
like people who think we're being like
doxy this is New York City man he's good
they've got this isn't how it works
there
they all work in big ass buildings with
or yeah yeah no it's it's very yeah it's
it's not the same as like uh like a
straight up uh residence plus there was
a lot of news articles on it as well I'm
very curious because I don't think he
even lives in it like it's just like one
of his property girlfriends
so yeah
um he's trying to sell it for like 6.5
million and my suspicion is
he put it out there for like three times
almost the the normal market rate
specifically because he thought either
one because he's out of his mind
narcissistic ego maniacal and suspected
that like someone would be like Oh I'm
such a Rudy Giuliani head uh this is
going to be really important for me like
that's his apartment that looks uh no
there's no shot right that's not no I
just well this is the building yeah
that's a that's probably one of the
remodeled like more modern units 20
million bro
that's probably the penthouse maybe is
that well that might be that's probably
that's the building perhaps no no crazy
a New York building doesn't go for 20
million no no no I'm telling you I
looked it up gotta be a floor I looked
it up Rudy giuliani's apartment he was
trying to sell it for 6.5 million and
the latest unit in his apartment that
had been sold that was a little bit
smaller however was remodeled and had
like modern cabinets and whatnot had
gone for like 2.7 million or something
all right
I'm trying to find this it's so funny
that three times they're going all right
so what's his address 44 East 86 or is
that the one you pulled up Dan no here
it is I think I found it
um let's see it God is this his address
uh
444 nope it's not even not even close
mother of the Dead where did you
pull that one from I don't know I just
typed Rudy Giuliani apartment and it
came up yeah that one the the link that
you sent the last one you Giuliana put
6.5 million Manhattan apartment on the
market I believe that shows uh
uh oh no it doesn't show the other ones
um but anyway there was photos on it I
don't know where they went but
I love that they bought it already I
love that one is classified as landmark
in 1977. okay it's got Gothic inspired
terracotta and brick facade
um it is of course some some of the more
notable things about the apartment
itself the home was the target of a 2021
raid by the FBI agents during a program
Ukraine
it's like wow this is this is what I say
for all the ghouliani heads out there
you know this this is where
Giuliani asked for those tits to come
over here that's dude why didn't they
mention that in this I mean it's a
selling point
maybe that's why he's trying to sell
over 6.5 million but anyway he's trying
to put it up on the market I I suspect
partially because he's out of his
mind all right here's some
photos of it okay
and also because he thinks maybe someone
will buy it for that price
because there's some real Giuliani heads
out there or I think like maybe he
thinks a shadow donor in like Trump's
side can like
slide some money his way oh for his
legal fees interesting like like a rich
you know ho he's maybe doing a Hail Mary
there with like some billionaire that
makes more some billionaire to pay like
way above asking uh you know asking
price let's see
79 has owned the 10th floor Co-op
apartment and a landmark Gothic style
brick building from the early 1900s
since acquiring it 2002 according to
proper records he bought it for 4.8 so I
mean definitely the property values have
gone up significantly since 2002. so it
must seem off it doesn't seem like
crazily priced am I crazy why does it
say what 1.8 million in 2002 yeah it
would be worth like double uh based on
yeah yeah that does make sense I I don't
know why maybe I'm maybe I'm crazy like
I don't know an apartment Upper East
Side dude I'm fascinated by uh New York
City real estate because like I thought
it was relatively affordable when I saw
the two seven uh for one of the
apartments that's insane I feel like you
can't buy you can buy Like a Pill Box
for that price that's crazy
um I'm I'm fascinated because being rich
like being worth tens of millions of
dollars let's say isn't enough money to
get a nice apartment in Manhattan it's
not yeah the really nice apartments that
are like on Central Park the beautiful
new apartments are like 100 over a
hundred million dollars I swear to God
look it up I mean it's not I believe you
but that's crazy it's like uh like gold
it's fascinating go to Zillow
search for Manhattan and then sort it by
high prices
and you'll see this is like 5 000 square
foot Apartments I mean which is huge for
New York City but not that big anyway
kind of beside the point here's
ghouliani
yo I can't wait for ghoulie to skip on
his bond and then get he's going to get
a bounty hunter dude that's what I said
yesterday on stream I was like dude I
would I would literally like I think
bounty hunting is kind of gross uh
filming is like doubly gross even though
it makes for great content when your Dog
the Bounty Hunter but
this is the one-off where like I would
strap a GoPro on my chest and go bounty
hunting for Rudy Giuliani yeah I would
team up with with Dog the Bounty Hunter
whichever gross ass bounty
hunters out there that like normally
makes a living off of like filming
themselves tasing like random civilians
you know what I mean they're empowered
by the uh you know best interests of uh
I would love to be a part of that
process and it's just it's for the it's
for the adventure it's for the journey
not the destination you know I don't
even give a about like nabbing him
at the end of it just want to tase him
all right let's move on to some Goofs
and then we'll get into the meat of it
Ted Cruz is a we all knew that but
a friend of mine out in La just took
this picture of the 405 and yes all the
news and media Outlets you have
permission to use this wild
I I love this because like this is such
a classic it's such a classic photo
there's a shark on the freeway
it's such an old classic photo how the
do you fall for it and uh Ted Cruz
uh quotes holy crap dude
yeah this man thinks that there's a
shark on the 405 freeway yeah
um I I love the ocean is connecting to
the 405 freeway yeah they were so
whenever like these insane disasters
happen everybody and I myself included
we like always rush to do the whole like
lol look at you
uh a little bit of a little bit of
freezing destroyed your entire energy
Grid or whatever you know like it
happened in Texas uh everyone rushes to
gloat not realizing that like every
other part of America also has their own
very unique set of problems that would
not exist in any in any other part of
the country
um so I think Ted Cruz was getting real
horny to be like haha California you
couldn't deal with it you couldn't deal
with a little bit of rain California
like I think that's what he was trying
to do
and that's why he like pulled the
trigger too quickly I think I think
actually we were at least La dealt with
the rain pretty well I think
unfortunately because the rain wasn't as
bad as we thought I mean it was
significant we had like over four inches
in 24 hours that's insane
I like that before he did the classic
thing though
he he replied to his own tweet he said
I'm told this is a joke in L.A you never
know and everyone stays safe from the
storm or otherwise could be real you
never know this is says a lot about
society that I thought it was real
that's all it's it's Ted Cruz is the
dude who thinks there's sharks in a
swimming pool so he keeps his toes up
when he swims give us a valid fear I'm
just saying
um Rhonda santis is a soulless freak I
mean what in the God's name is this and
this isn't the only time he had another
really memorable his teeth are gritting
he's he's literally he's rolling dude
look at his jaw
he holy crap he's on MDMA I don't know
what's happening to him he looks like
he's in pain all the time like he's like
forced to act out human emotion
and
and you can see like behind those eyes
there's so much pain okay he actually
looks
more
up more convincing of a role than
homelander does like if homelander
pulled this off I would think like holy
this guy needs a this guy's a
genius
it's stunning I mean I can't stop
looking at it
Behind Blue Eyes you don't know what
it's like to be hated
to being faded
[Music]
Behind Blue Eyes
there's more there's some from the
debate as well there's like skip to that
one just there's some real there are
some real freak moments for little
Rhonda on on the new stage can you link
me to hit the other crazy look he did
during the debate
because yes that one was also here it's
uh
yeah the teeth grinding definitely
implies that he's on something that's
not a normal dude
here is uh the other one during the
debate not let you down
watch there's a moment right there
where you see that
he licks his teeth not let you down
oh
God I mean it's like there's this Tim
and Eric sketch I love where the guess
who's who's not Jackie Chan
okay yeah and he smiles the same way he
he's just
and I will not let you down
what is it about him I don't know why
he has no Charisma whatsoever like
Charisma he is so awkward he hasn't even
convinced me that he's a human being you
need to be a humanoid I think well dogs
have Charisma more Charisma than him
what dogs yeah there is infinitely more
charismatic
I can't get over it I just I I
I cringe every time I see him it's very
he's very gross I'm always like ew why
are you showing me this well he is
getting dominated he's dropping he's
taking L's and I see why the man is just
yeah freak um are we are we diving into
the GOP debate one more quick goof and
then we will okay uh new GOP Ops is
crushing Biden they have
uh uncovered the horror truth he what he
cares about dogs
yeah this one this one was pretty
devastating RNC research tweeted out by
it was distracted by a dog quote that's
some hot ground man as a as a sociopath
uh as a sociopathic person who who kills
adopted puppies for fun I really thought
you know what a Zinger this is really
going to destroy uh Joe Biden's approval
rating
I'm ready to make I'm ready to make
eating dogs normal acceptable behavior
this is this is this was this was it for
me me and me and like eight other people
that hate dogs apparently what
the so here it is
[Music]
he has a hard time leaning over though
that's that I noticed man yeah he's not
he also did the proper thing that you're
supposed to do when you introduce
yourself to a dog which is like you know
let them smell the back of your hand and
you're not normally supposed to go for
the head like that but that's fine it's
a service animal so it's probably
anywhere else yeah
but
um even when he's leaning over to make
the hand smell uh happen he's just like
having a hard time aiming it right
[Music]
my future
just catch the boots out here
oh the dog's wearing boots no he says
you guys got some boots out here the
ground is hot oh well he's right I mean
I listen I want that doggy have
comfortable feet yeah on on black
asphalt let's go you guys catch the
boots out here
[Music]
that's a hot brown man that's
live on the hot ground yeah run around
with with tomatoes and watermelon dogs
sitting on my lap
I love sitting on the hot ground that
that that that that
I got hairy legs sitting on the ground
hot ground I don't know why the the
RNC team was like this is the perfect
opportunity to destroy your body it's
very human and relatable and I don't
even know that he would thought he was
being recorded seemed like a hot mic
yeah it's uh yeah no he was just being
himself
um also I think it should be legal for
me to Pet Service animals I know like
not like you know for service animals
for like the blind even though like I I
still want to but you know I understand
but if you're like uh one of those cop
dogs or whatever like a drug sniffing
dog like and I'm at the airport where
there unfortunately aren't that many
dogs around okay I should be able to get
one pet in they're such good boys too if
you're it good though if you're if
you're looking at me if you're sir if
your canine unit is looking at me that
dog is gonna get pet
it's I am like that is reasonable that
is right I am Mr service weapon uh
Grabber but for dogs you know what I
mean I just like if I see a cop and a
dog I'm like I have to pay your dog I'm
sorry I will look you right in the eyes
and be like arrest me for the crime of
you know doing the most normal thing
possible well the other part that makes
it so hard to resist is that they're I'm
just so proud of them
for serving our country well they're
just they're just such good dogs you
know what I mean it sucks that they're
forced to like you know do something
that's awful but they're so I'm just
proud of them because they're so good
they are good they don't know what
they're doing you know what I mean
they're just being good yeah yeah
they're just they're just being good
boys and girls you're right all right
let's move on we got all kinds to talk
about let's get into uh here's a nice
little breakdown from New York Times
about who
uh got the most camera time most
speaking time what this is surprising me
Pence was number one
I mean I watched the debate and I didn't
that's kind of surprised me I thought
it'd be uh ramaswamy no I I understand
Pence did get a lot of air time uh most
of it was boring and dull but he came
across very assertive I thought
um not that it matters I just wanna
before we even talk about any of this
these guys all suck okay their approval
rate I mean their their poll numbers are
dog water they are terrible they are not
gonna they're not gonna move the needle
in a significant direction that uh
starts eating away at Trump's uh poll
numbers I think Vivid could take a tiny
chunk out of it I agree with that most I
don't even think he would take a chunk
out of trump but I think he would take a
trunk out of like everybody else's
because like everybody else has like
some Donald Trump supporters that are
like but maybe I like this guy you know
what I mean maybe yeah
but Pence got everyone to agree that
um he did the right thing by that was
really unique by certifying the vote I'm
surprised by that uh that crowd was
insane okay so confused because they
were they were clapping at Mike Pence
saying I put my you know oath to the
office above my loyalty to the president
yeah and like
at one point that got collapse and then
immediately after uh you know Rama Swami
would like dunk on Chris Christie and be
like shut the up Donald Trump was
the president you should Penn shouldn't
have done that or whatever and then that
would get clapsed yeah and it made no
sense like what the was going on in
that audience I found myself wondering
who actually is in the audience like
genuinely who was invited there not like
jokingly I think maybe like uh a lot of
the Republican parties uh obvious
primary base of support is Republican uh
Trump supporters so I think half of the
room was like real voters and then the
other half was all like lobbyists right
and you know Republican Party
uh uh members well more loyal to the
party please clap I knew this about uh
is it vivec how do you say his first
name Vivek ramaswamy Vivek okay uh
ramaswamy I knew it was like
conservative and pretty nutty but man he
is like he is
it's not a secret but he has a way of
presenting himself as like reasonable
and logical and
and kind of just Factor the matter but
his views are really really they're not
real he's just 100
triangulating to like uh to to Trump
dick riding uh cabinet position not sure
I I do love that a lot of people on
Twitter are like oh my God Vivek is
angling for a vice president's position
for the Trump taking and I'm like you're
out of your mind okay you guys
are so crazy if you think that the
Republican party is going to make like
it think about it this way
the vice president's last name shows up
next to the president's last name on
campaign slogans so so you think that
they're going to do what Trump ramaswamy
ramaswamy Republicans are going to vote
for a man with the last name Rama Swami
no shot okay Bobby Jindal tried
it didn't work out it's not happening I
was in some comments and I already saw
people being like of the art of the
their base being like super racist
against Indians he will he will gain
some prominence because I think uh he is
angling towards like the online and the
younger Republicans in a way that Ron
DeSantis was trying to angle towards the
extremely online young republics but
Rama Swami does that better yeah which
creates an inflated sense of popularity
in in especially Twitter and by that I
mean this angling now
uh for the Contemporary Republican party
for Gen Z Republicans and Millennial
Republicans is just being as fascist as
possible right straight up and I mean
like like advocating for like esoteric
fascist uh right and
um
that does not play that well with the
broader base of Republican voters
because like they don't want to be
uh like they don't want the black Sun
Association uh that Ron DeSantis uh
accidentally uh accidentally allowed in
his campaign so Rama Swami's been able
to avoid that while still simultaneously
signaling the same exact like extremely
online 4chan uh you know foreign policy
and whatnot
overall
um he was
he he I had this guttural disgust this
visceral disgust to the things that he
was saying
and whenever I have that kind of feeling
towards a particular candidate
I know that that probably plays well
with the Republican voters
that's a good point whereas like with
Ron DeSantis I just have a feeling of
sadness
or whenever he speaks I'm like oh that's
gross the thing that I find interesting
about Vivek is that he's a billionaire
and he's doing the same exact stick that
Trump did where he's like I'm the
outsider I'm not like other politicians
and he's even more of like a billionaire
Insider almost than Trump is he's like a
tech no billionaire who is clearly
representing his own and his crony's
interests and somehow convincing people
that he's just hey I'm just like one of
you he's a Pharma industry bro who the
the Republicans apparently hate yeah so
he's like the same Playbook I heard him
saying that a few times on the stage he
was he he was on the world economic
Forum like he he promised with he got a
George Soros Grant when he was already a
millionaire in college oh
brother so like not Georgie boy yeah so
like the fact that the Republicans are
actually like hand waving that away
speaks to like Rama Swami's instincts
um because Fox News has run some
articles on it and overall because of
his like die hard support for Donald
Trump right
um people are kind of hand waving all
that away he feels like a real one but
this is kind of like the Democratic
party trying to recreate Barack Obama
Barack Obama was a once in a lifetime
candidate who was incredibly charismatic
especially when he was running Donald
Trump in many respects is the uh Barack
Obama for white people he was white
man's Barack Obama in the sense that he
was incredibly charismatic and still is
incredibly charismatic to a specific
subsect of the population okay
um and you're not going to be able to
recreate that with someone like Vivek
Donald Trump didn't actually play The
Outsider I'm a billionaire I'm a I'm a
businessman role because he was a
billionaire businessman the reason why
he got a lot of um the reason why people
loved him was because he was a
television star he was a person who was
in pop culture he ran a show uh called
The Apprentice that was uh one of the
most diverse casts on reality television
and had some of the most diverse
marketing uh that you had ever seen like
as far as demographics goes all that
stuff
um gave him a tremendous amount of
uh name recognition that that truly
helped them solidify his Outsider
perspective when I
heard from Trump supporters I did
frequently hear from them that he's a
businessman we ain't a businessman who's
going to run the country like a
businessman and I get the same since
they have that they have that uh
reverence for for uh Vivek Vivek Vivek
yeah Vivek yeah but here's the thing
Doug burgum is a businessman he's a
billionaire too who well he's a exactly
exactly
like Doug burgum is businessman dude
he's a billionaire I mean he kept
repeating over and over again he he's
from a town with 300 people I'm from a
town of 300 people that guy billionaire
I didn't know that yeah he's a
billionaire and
um
and surprised that none of them because
they were all trying to hit uh uh Vivek
and
nobody mentioned that he's a Pharma
billionaire and I feel like why not yeah
here's one thing I'll say
mm-hmm Americans might especially on the
Republican Party might say they want a
businessman
but they're not voting for a businessman
because of their Bona fides in business
if that was the case Mitt Romney would
have cleared Barack Obama I mean Romney
was the ultimate businessman
at Bain
um and yet his businessman's status and
his in his experience in that field
uh was weaponized against them they they
said you are the Liquidator you're the
guy that comes in and fires a bunch of
people you're responsible for Mass
layoffs when you were doing consulting
um you're a bad guy and it
worked they portrayed him as an out of
touch uh wealthy guy
um because he is so I think Vivek
is not necessarily going to be able to
play the Trump role because what made
Trump popular isn't necessarily that
he's a businessman it's that he's a
television businessman
he played one on TV basically right well
here's here you can expect all the most
annoying people in your life to start
supporting uh
oh an earthquake earthquake we're having
a little bit of an earthquake that's
crazy yo this I don't know about this
building holding up good in the
earthquake boy don't say that
um
that was a small one yeah I loved it but
do you know what I'm saying dude we
might die why no we're fine
Northridge
I thought dogs are supposed to have like
like a second sense or something yeah
she did not give a my dogs
generally don't notice either oh there's
been a lot of earthquakes lately so yeah
that's my first ever earthquake oh
really yeah oh congratulations congrats
popped an earthquake cherry
did you feel that this you notice it at
all uh this one yeah yeah a little bit
yeah
let's see who characters
but if the one during the storm was
bigger I didn't feel that I feel that
way yeah that one wasn't very big either
uh there was one recently that happened
in La it was like a three-pointer or
something but I felt it a lot because it
was close well there was one during the
hurricane that was 5-0 yeah right it was
in Ojai so it wasn't very big in LA but
5-0 is Big yeah I felt pretty
significant I felt it on stream it shook
me
uh yeah so uh Elon Musk is supporting uh
uh Vivek and so therefore you couldn't
uh expect all your most annoying people
in your life he was impressive he says
yeah becoming increasingly uh
uh I'm I'm grossed out by him and I
think that he's like uh dick riding
Trump for short-term benefits I do not
think that he is like a he has like a
real viable shot obviously
but uh having said that we'll see how it
plays out I want to look I want to see
his poll numbers after this because
this either goes uh two ways either
everybody's like you know that Vivid
he's one of the good ones I like that
kind of I like that guy because a lot of
people were Googling him immediately
after and usually
the unknown entity especially if they
get that much speaking time like they're
the front runner and everyone's
attacking them
a lot of people are going to uh you know
get more interested in him
this should this can give you some info
they did a poll on who they think won
okay Rama Swami won Trump got second the
man wasn't there yeah then and Pence
just to tell you who got the most time
he was at eight percent so nobody really
even gives a
but this guy really creeped me
out Hutchinson dude that guy is oh my
God I don't like him at all just wait
this morning uh I found in the Trump uh
Tucker interview he talks some on
him and it's really yeah funny he's got
a weird baby face I call him Ada
Hutchinson I Can't Tell You Why don't
ask why I would I think women who take
who do abortions should be murdered I
believe that abortion wait I think
you're wait are you mistaking him with
Mike Pence
no he's he's was saying the most
hardcore about abortion yeah so I I
think that uh Aza Hutchinson is like the
first version that the aliens brought
back to earth like sent down to earth
and they were like oh God he looks too
much like a ghoul they're not believing
him we need to yassify him a little bit
so they sent Mike Pence instead got it
Mike this is kind of handsome put
together yeah they Mike Pence is like
the yassified as a Hutchinson try it
right right azodges is like so hard to
look at he's such a ghoul he's
such a demon he's creepy uh Matt Welsh
was of course pissed because Fox didn't
ask the right questions I've only
watched the clips dude you don't watch
the whole debate this is like your whole
life did Fox really go the whole debate
and not ask a single question about
child mutilation and gender ideology
which has been by far the biggest
cultural issue in the country for
multiple years now nomad but they did
ask about Richmond north of Richmond
yeah so here's the thing here's the
thing I wonder I wonder if Matt Walsh
will recognize that perhaps
like that even in the Republican Party
primaries is not exactly seen as a
winning issue it just comes
across like it's gross and weird because
it is gross and weird to be constantly
thinking about mutilating children you
freak I want to have a
discussion about miners genitals go
ahead your thoughts like of course they
talked about some dumb like I don't
know climate change is it real uh rich
men north of Richmond Oliver Anthony's
new single that was so awesome yeah man
that was their opening bit first
question I was like yo the most pressing
question of all time
they did not mention to Chris Christie
the fudge rounds I know they that would
have been great Chris uh Chris your
thoughts on the fudge rounds uh comment
should fat people be able to eat fudge
rounds on EBT people exist your thoughts
should should fat people be allowed to
continue to live your thoughts
yeah
um the big breakout was Roman Swami we
know he's surging uh CNN did a live
Focus poll on ramaswamy
so he and I'll say this um
I'm excited to say Hassan
that Rama Swami's people got back to us
oh they did yeah they're trying to work
out the details of his impulse
oh wait oh you can't come in oh
can't come in person no he asked no no
they they asked Which Way But I just
prefer Zoom calls okay preference all
right I'm down but but they offered they
said per in person or Zoom so I think
that could be a fantastic opportunity
for for us all to have a okay I'll do
this I'll do person I don't give a
I mean my my biggest problem with this
debate is the same thing with all of
them it's just so
unserious like I don't think there was
one follow-up question by the moderators
the entire night I mean they say they
literally just have pre-planned talking
points they're completely unchallenged
they're completely they also got out of
control quite a few times that's normal
these days it's just like whatever but
nobody ever had to explain themselves
like they would say like
you know
people coming in from the border
murdering tens of thousands of people or
whatever a hyperbole and nobody asked
them to explain
what they mean and it's just you know
it's pathetic it's not a real debate
um
these are journalists I mean aren't they
embarrassed this isn't journalism
they're not they're not a single
follow-up it's Fox News they literally
just reading off a page not just box
though the debates have always been dog
in this yeah you know what I mean
well it's just it's hard to watch
because it's just so
uh it has no substance at all it's just
really a pathetic show of who's got
better zingers and it's all phony and
none of them really even believe what
they're saying uh it's just such
man
you know
who hates climate change War I
hate climbing change the most dude that
okay so it's really interesting oh
two things I want to say here really
interesting that they brought a Young
Americans for Freedom guide that looked
exactly like young Ben Shapiro by the
way to ask about climate change and and
not immediately dismiss it either he was
saying like this is the number one issue
that the youth cares about what are your
thoughts on it yeah it was a good
question Rhonda said to immediately Dove
on that grenade and was like let's have
it you know let's have a real
conversation or whatever we wouldn't
talk about it like but he but he didn't
actually like he just sidestepped he
saved everyone because the question was
put up your hand if you believe in
man-made climate change which is by the
way such a layup because like you can
believe in man-made climate change and
then also be like but I don't think it's
a big deal no I don't even think that
that no not for the Republican base I
think that the Republican base would
have been like that's that's coward
that's Chinese conspiracy and he's uh
he's a part of it well like you said
that's a good analogy DeSantis jumped on
the grenade is like this is a classroom
so nobody actually had to be held again
which I hate and then Vivek jumped on
Ron desantis's grenade and said it's a
hoax it's a hoax all these people on
stage are our cowards I will be the only
one with the balls to say it global
climate change is a hoax he says that's
one point or that I'd love to have a
detailed conversation with him you know
you know well let me let me uh do you
one better
he has in the past not that long ago a
couple months ago openly admitted
recognized that climate change is real
well that seems to be contrary oh so
what I think what he would say is
it's not man-made climate change it's a
natural uh you know cycles and the Earth
swarming and cooling I'm almost certain
there is a video out there from a news
broadcast where he says man-made climate
change is real and it's only from a
couple months back okay but here he is
with the most psycho take out there but
this was a weird moment because well
we'll see you in a second but be honest
get some booze for this no I think you
were mistaken on that yeah they were
booing that he called everybody else
a fraud or whatever he said everyone
else is bought and paid for uh and the
people were booing him for that and it
okay bled over on the stage who isn't
bought and paid for so I can say this
the climate change agenda is
I think they're booing that yeah the
booing you're right it starts to kind of
yeah
the Donald Trump thing like I'm the only
person who's not bought and paid for on
the stage and it's like it fails to
recognize that it's not because he's a
rich guy if Americans had that level of
reverence like across the board just for
rich people he's doing the outsider
thing then Michael Bloomberg
would have would have been fine you know
what I mean or or any number of other
Democratic billionaires that ran there
was that other one from California who
was actually an outsider you know what I
mean he's appealing to The Outsider
thing I don't necessarily think it's the
rich thing but this guy who's is this
the billionaire or was it uh this guy is
this guy billionaire is he just a freak
man whatever I mean a lot of them are
rich but
there it is and that's that's what we
need the world needs is America to be
the leader to say climate change is a
hoax fracking oil digging one thing I
didn't like that he said is we need to
embrace nuclear which I wholeheartedly
believe I will also say that real quick
sorry go ahead I will say that uh
the response that I was seeing online
um
is that what she do oh she's chewing
wires sorry wires
oh Kaya did she was she not gonna get
electrocuted
oh you do okay
all right go ahead Dad sorry I was
trying to say the uh the uh kind of um
Nuance that I saw some on the right like
the less psycho ones like you were
saying that somewhat except that climate
change maybe might be a little bit real
is that what's a hoax is the climate
change agenda that's what he said that
specifically the climate change agenda
right so I believe in climate change I
just don't believe in doing
[Music]
ha ha
I didn't that didn't feel necessary I
don't take chances oh that was Zach
laughing I forgot you were here I don't
take chances anymore
um like timed like yeah I don't know
they make up oh they do like this the
climate change agenda means they don't
want us to eat hamburgers anymore like
these invented silly shits like that
but uh that's our boy V Vivek Vivek give
me a headache
hmm
let's watch this live focus group of uh
repubs talking about the Vivek I want to
ask about who you thought did the best
during this debate basically who do you
think won the debate
do an alphabetical order to be fair
anyone think Doug burgum did the best
LOL I don't know I don't think Chris
Christie did the best he certainly got
most of the air time a lot of the earth
I'm not most of the air time how about
Ron DeSantis how many of you think Ron
DeSantis are the best that's two people
how about Nikki Haley
one two three four people interested ASA
Hutchinson
zero I love these hence
damn not one person like Mike
Pence wow who likes my pants yeah I
thought at least he got one damn bow no
shot he had the most speaking time no
shot he's he's a traitor one Rama Swami
four five six seven look at the age look
at the age look at the age groups true
true true look at the age groups that's
huge oh man you're so right they're all
the young people that's one old
here one old guy yeah
maybe two actually two older guys but
you're right that it's mostly the young
people five six seven Tim Scott
breaker Nation stand up this panel here
so Nikki Haley got the second of most
which is interesting
takes I remember Nikki Haley actually is
probably
the ah
she might be one of the smartest
candidates running
um she definitely understands the
spiritual problem that the Republican
party has like the existential issues
that they have for the Republican party
in general and its success for future uh
for future elections
however she's awful at communicating
that in a way that
um in a way that Republicans will
respond positively to in a way she's
like a Democratic Party candidate
because Republicans
and I've said this so many times
Republicans will tell their base no
matter how difficult or how impossible a
certain piece of legislation could be to
pass they'll do it they'll be like no
we're making abortions illegal you want
it we're going to give it to you we're
going to give you an AR-15 we're going
to give your baby an AR-15 we're making
it mandatory you know children without
AR-15s are going to get shot if there is
a if there's a 30 loyal base of support
in the Republican Party Republican
candidates no matter how impossible it
is they'll say they'll do it and usually
they'll take 35 years to like end up
actually accomplishing those tasks but
that's a whole different story no matter
how unpopular it is
Nikki Haley on the other hand behaved
like a Democrat what do I mean by that
Democrats always tell you politics is
the art of what's possible I'm sorry oh
you want Healthcare what else do you
want you want a unicorn you want a pony
uh you want free college right we can't
do that we can't do that for you you're
gonna shut the up and you're gonna
vote for us Nikki Haley
did a Nikki Healey's write about the
issues of the Republican party that she
very clearly communicated specifically
on abortion for example right but the
way that she described how not possible
it was to do an abortion ban at the
federal level was literally
just saying like oh we've never had more
than 45 pro-life senators
like
that's an idiotic way to address the
issue just say that it is not as popular
as you think it is okay somebody did say
that I thought I don't remember I
thought somebody mentioned that that
they're like this is a losing issue like
the people just don't want I don't know
larger would just happen uh you know
what it wasn't it wasn't about abortion
they were actually you know what I think
what you're thinking of is DeSantis
about larger my mic is is drooping on
yeah
Viagra for my mic go ahead sorry Dan it
was DeSantis about uh January 6th
is what you're thinking of where he's
like really litigating this and talking
about Trump is a losing issue
yeah but they're Americans want to look
at January 24
2024 not January 6 2021.
yeah but in general there was like I
guess
Mass
uh rejection of climate change and mass
uh everybody there is pretending to be
like fully Pro oh that was one thing
that pissed me off during the
abortion
conversation is there like California
and New York and States like that they
allow abortion until they're for
abortion until the day of birth and I'm
like
can we please stop saying that like can
we clarify that no it's so they will
never stop like those moderators
just correct just say something no
they say it too they say it on their
broadcast why would they ever correct it
that's so pathetic because that's the
only real but that's the only valid
counter to like the situation because
the reality on the ground is you got 14
year old rape victims that are being
forced to carry pregnancies the term uh
you got women with ectopic pregnancies
that doctors are terrified to actually
abort medically because they don't want
legal scrutiny
um that is the real that is the reality
on the ground people are experiencing
that people are seeing that Republicans
are seeing that Republicans get
abortions too Republicans have
Mistresses Republicans have
daughters Republicans have wives that
also want to get abortions or need it in
the case of a medical emergency so
um they don't want to talk about that so
they always go back to like ridiculous
made up the only reason why people
get having abortion just casually having
abortion the only reason why people get
abortions in the third trimester is due
to Medical emergencies okay that is like
the like there might be one to five
people that like didn't realize they
were pregnant in like a super Edge case
but beyond that
that doesn't happen no it does sometimes
one out of five no no no no one or five
one oh five they said one out of five no
I'm saying like out of the you know
thousands of abortions but you can we
know 92 happens in the first time
abortion that late unless it's like a
medical emergency yes you it's in
California it's uh fetal viability yeah
you cannot get an abortion after the
fetus is capable of living third
trimester third trimester abortions like
last trimester abortions
only happen if there is a viability of
the fetus at uh issue or uh via a
carrier issue like if there's a if
there's an issue that like the the fetus
is uh constricting or hurting the life
of the conversation was just so
annoying because like and they go I
think there might be there might be some
uh full-blown uh Choice uh third
trimester abortions though I don't think
so none but very very like in is
unimaginably Slim
I just don't I I genuinely don't think
that it's legal and I think it's
important to me I mean we could find out
of course
but they go we need why can't everybody
agree that we need like a 20-week
abortion ban and it's like everybody
does agree they painting out
Californians and New Yorkers and liberal
states to be like Monsters they just
want to kill babies the day before
they're born which is like it's just so
stupid
yeah it was frustrating the watch it
just such a nonsense
here is uh the first question of debate
they're talking about our boy
uh Mr fudge rounds
are you guys all you guys are fact
checking the abortion thing I'm I'm
looking at it right now
I mean it's it's such a dumb people
viability yeah you cannot you cannot get
an abortion passed 91 91 of abortions
are happening uh in the 13 week at or
before the 13th it's important to say
though that it's illegal to get
abortions pacifiability don't even leave
open the option that like oh you can do
this if you want
because once is enough for them the only
time you can do it is if a doctor says
that you're gonna die or the baby's
gonna die and there's Health yeah
there's no also there's no like doctors
get to cut the baby's head off with a
guillotine as it's coming out of the
womb type like that that is just
like made up it went viral due to
um uh uh Virginia uh Kathy Tran uh who
who uh was asked about a new legislation
under consideration or that had passed
in several States would allow an
abortion moments after birth made
headlines and in the 30-second clip a
republican asked China whether a woman
in labor would be allowed to have an
abortion and she answered yes translator
said she misspoke and that such a
procedure would not be allowed she
clearly know because infanticide is not
allowed in Virginia and that would have
happened the moment that was a live
birth holy that's nuts so it
doesn't even matter every single person
has said that's completely not allowed
but it doesn't matter Republicans have
been running with that for literally
since that that uh sound bite that 30
second sound might happen if the
moderators did a an a time even like a a
gram of of uh journalism but it's too
much to expect here is uh their first
question
It Is by a singer from Farmville
Virginia named Oliver Anthony
well I was cringing when I saw this I
was like oh my it's brutal God it's
brutal the first question
alienation of deep frustration with the
state of government and of this country
and fat people
um
that was the main point I saw
100 miles
mile of Richmond
[Music]
I'm so sick of seeing they're
all Richmond north of Richmond by the
way look every single one of them he's
talking about yeah they're politicians
like what the going on here
that's the point of her question I guess
but like they're all like not me
he's not singing about me of course
singing about these other kid boys on
the stage
[Music]
[Applause]
all of them just having to stand there
that people should die
Romney's loving it look at the big smile
I'm so touched so Governor DeSantis no
no no keep playing it guys
striking such a nerve in this country
right now what do you think this is such
a bad question this country is in
Decline this decline is not inevitable
it's a choice we need to send Joe Biden
back to his basement and then like he
really doesn't even they the amount of
times that anyone actually answers the
question is like none I would like to
clear something up about the abortion
conversation go ahead really quickly
there are no elective third trimester
abortions that are allowed
in the United States of America yeah
of course States however do allow third
trimester abortions the political term
for this is a late term abortion which
is that's not a medical term
they made that up
the uh the common
uh law I guess the common uh allowance
availability
uh what is legally permissible is is
very similar to the New York law which
allows for women after 24 weeks of
pregnancy to get an abortion if there is
an absence of fetal viability like we
talked about or the abortion is
necessary to protect the patient's life
or health
that second part is what Republicans are
oftentimes disputing and is what they
claim is actually they use this
they do this trick where they say oh
well gestation and like uh viability
outside of the womb due to Medical
Technology actually greatly improved and
now fetuses can live outside
nuanced of a conversation yeah it
doesn't matter of course they're not
going to make that nuance and that
Nuance also is it's
what do you mean oh uh
viability outside of the womb is
important so like what you have to like
get a cesarean uh C-section and and
forcibly carry a pregnancy to term like
that's insane and the second part of the
conversation is they don't believe that
like the the uh patient the carrier's
life or death oh Shredder's here
the necessity to protect the carrier is
an important one they think that it's
well even that would be a more
a less offensive even though it's
because what they said on the
stage was just straight up
Democrats they are just cool with
abortion yeah they're lying I mean yeah
they're just lying it's just pathetic
hot dog it's Shredder
um
there it is
what else we got here
I mean it's a healthcare procedure the
the fact that like these
are are sitting there talking
about like a health care procedure that
is medically necessary that should
absolutely be allowed that is allowed
that doesn't actually even render the
process itself uh that doesn't actually
like eliminate the process it just makes
it much more unsafe uh for the women
because like uh abortion bans don't
actually stop abortions from happening
it just makes them it just forces women
to get them in back alley abortions
which create Healthcare Health
complications later down the line and
infertility
um is is just ridiculous but they have
to do it on the basis of Lies
why would they talk about it from a
truthful uh perspective yeah because
it's right
uh everybody was going after uh Vivek
Chris Christie come on with the master
slam dude tonight and this one really
offended me frankly I took this one
personally who sounds like Chachi BT
excuse me
you're a big chat GPT guy hell yeah
these debates Brett who stood in the
middle of the stage and said what's a
skinny guy with an odd last name doing
up here was Barack Obama and I'm afraid
we're dealing with the same type of
amateur that was a really interesting
disc what did you think about that it's
true that a young man with a weird name
no that's Barack Obama Barack Obama said
it said that at the DNC convention yeah
huh
yeah he said exactly those same words
which Vivek 100 ripped but it doesn't
matter
because Republicans are too
stupid for for that kind of dis to
register
they probably didn't even see that the
chat GPT one was good though it was
Punchy I like that one yeah dork he's
like four eye dork yeah
smart loser problem is he didn't keep
that energy problem is he kept trying to
like talk about how like Trump is bad
and uh and and represents a threat to
like America or whatever the he was
saying and he 100 lost the war of
attrition on that stage you could see
that he was fatigued by the second half
of the debate everyone was ripping into
him uh he was he was weak I'm talking
about Vivek or no I'm talking about
Chris Christopher oh yeah well you know
what Trump would say
say he's fat yeah
no he would point to the crowd and go
Don't Call Him a fat pig
it's definitely not because he hasn't
eaten since we started folks don't say
that he needs a meal he's hungry
uh here's Nikki Haley popping off on our
boy
don't talk about our boy like that
Vivek is a win for China we have to know
that Ukraine is the first line of
defense for us and the problem that
vivec doesn't understand is this is so
bipartisan according to Russia he wants
to let China eat Taiwan he wants to go
you can let her off
you come
yeah they're fine
yeah it's fine
I mean they're used they got to get used
to each other they are pretty much
they'll be cool right right Shredder
everyone's thirsty all right uh thank
you love funding by the way I'm sorry I
know you just unpause but vivek's
foreign policy is insane
he is like
incomprehensible the issue of Ukraine I
think surprisingly I misunderstood uh
she was saying originally uh Ron
DeSantis despite his lack of Charisma
has figured out a way to triangulate it
a little bit better where uh I think
that the Republican party and the
Republican Party base of support is uh
going to be way more audibly frustrated
with like unlimited amounts of weapons
and money going into Ukraine right
so
they so I think that there is definitely
an appetite there for uh someone to say
we're not giving money to Ukraine we got
to revert those funds to like a war that
we care about like uh Mexico which we'll
get to in a second
um uh protecting our borders
but vivek's foreign policy is is so wild
it's like the most I felt like it was
the most 4-chan style foreign policy
I've ever heard where he's just like we
have to get
we have to get Russia on our side
because they're protecting I guess
because they're protecting whiteness in
white people and we have to attack China
well he didn't say the white people part
I'm I'm adding that okay that's why some
far-right Republicans like uh Russia
which is insane they're such dupes but
um so
let's watch this question who the heck
is this skinny guy with a funny last
name this is the the side by side of
what yeah Obama's ending yeah in the
middle of this debate stage well the
skinny kid with a funny name listen now
that everybody's gotten their memorized
pre-prepared slogans out of the way we
can actually have a real discussion now
who the heck is this what dude yeah that
he's straight a rip lifted that yeah
okay but getting back to it uh when
we're talking about uh Nikki Haley vivex
uh foreign policy positions are
incomprehensible Nikki Haley does like a
decent job of Towing the line here
but I do think Ron desantis's take is
better uh that is is better for the
Republican party at least where he says
like we need to stop giving funds to the
Ukraine like unlimited amounts of funds
to Ukraine
um
and you know we need to revert those
funds elsewhere but also
uh you know we're not gonna stop until
you know we want Europe to defend
Ukraine more you know what I mean like
the the classic Trump NATO line yeah
that like Trump is in favor of
abolishing NATO not really though he
just wants Europe to pay more right uh
for its own self-defense that's uh I
think that's a decent way to triangulate
on the Ukrainian issue for for the
Republican base
so let's hear what she says
win for Russia is a win for China we
have to know that
[Applause]
your stand is he wants to hand Ukraine
to Russia he wants to let China eat
Taiwan he wants to go and stop funding
Israel you don't do that to friends what
you do instead is you have the backs of
your friends Ukraine it's a front line
of defense Putin has said if Russia once
Russia takes Ukraine Poland and the
baltics are next that's a World War
we're trying to prevent war look at what
Putin did today he killed pergozin when
oh wasn't that epic that provosions
plane just crashed I know so iconic
Putin yeah I it just it just plans just
kind of do that though it's like he he's
so unsubtle about I mean what's it been
like two weeks I'm surprised took this
long it's like a little yeah
it was just so crazy too I heard it uh
as like a headline and on the radio and
they're like proposing uh who who led an
uprising gets Putin's plane crash today
they don't even like they're not even
like yeah Putin killed him they're like
well plane crashed well I mean that is
still technically true well yeah
usually planes crash after they get hit
by uh anti-air missiles yeah well I like
I like that the uh the Russian
authorities like their their statement
on it is uh you know
well first they're just first they uh
they were you know seeing who was in the
crash because they were trying to figure
out if progression it was using his
second plane because the second plane
landed uh he was known to swap planes
usually to avoid like assassination
attempts this one uh
now they're saying it was a Ukrainian uh
missile or something like that that had
for sure playing out yeah that
guy really up like he he he was
about to do it it was so he was about to
get it done and then you come with the
King you best not miss and then he's
just like okay cool you promised not to
kill me
you're good bro I promise I think it's
because he he does have like broad
popular support from the even further
right Coalition of nationalists like
Ultra nationalists in Russia nobody so
Putin he thought Putin would keep him
around specifically as a cudgel to be
like look there's other people that are
worse than me out there but I think he
does not respond
yeah man with with forgiveness I thought
if anybody knew that or that
um
you know uh surrender meant death I
thought it would be him but still at
least he didn't kill himself by jumping
out of a window yeah that happens so
much it's just so sad how many how many
Russian uh people that have uh oligarchs
they just jumping out of Windows they
always do that and then they have like
bad tea there's another one yeah spoiled
tea yeah you got to be careful with that
boy spoiled tea it doesn't kill you man
it's deadly yeah I once had a lift and
that was a few days expired boy yeah how
did that get there that in Rich uranium
how did that get in my tea that's crazy
it's like radon you know it's here it's
there it's everywhere you know just
don't know it just happens to be like a
million times and this cup of tea
Russian Ambassador suddenly died this
guy is a murderer and you are choosing a
murderer or I thought that was pretty
funny like well yeah you're gonna be a
murderer too if you become president
probably in the first day yeah
well I mean that's what's interesting
when they did the CNN poll uh and she
actually got four votes I think you know
she probably got those votes in that
moment when she popped off like that and
basically she she's kind of like the uh
the old school Republican she's like the
2000s Republican like the bush
Republican on the stage you know what I
mean
well I mean but Bush still had Charisma
you know what I mean Bush still yeah not
in that sense but just like the the the
the the positions that she's taking all
I'm saying is the Republican Party
complete okay let me say this much
Mitt Romney was a a revamp for the
Republican party they had noticed that
uh you know Latino immigration uh was
was changing the American demographic
they were looking at uh places like
Texas they were looking at places like
uh New Mexico Arizona
uh and realizing that like they need to
re-triangulate their message to be more
welcoming of of uh the Latino population
and not just cut uh straight up racial
adjective prop
ER Romney failed and then Donald Trump
came in to The Fray and he completely
demolished that he was like yeah he was
like no we're not doing that we're
calling Mexicans rapists and everyone
was like oh holy this works this
works really good one thing that they
actually even realized was oh my God
like Texas Latino uh voters 70 of uh
Latinos in this country Hispanics in the
country uh identify self-identify as
white by the way just an important
little factoid for people to understand
they love that they didn't give a
they were like oh my God that's
awesome especially older voters so then
they they dropped this uh kind of
civility politics and and trying to
focus on optics for just straight up
dropping the dog whistles and and
screaming with a bullhorn
and for that reason I think Nikki Haley
is you're right uh running on an old
Republican party uh uh agenda but that's
not there's not a lot of appetite for
that on the ground on the voter base
it's an old Playbook this was my
favorite moment of the night one of them
anyway
um
DeSantis uh being the pathetic loser he
is watch this
so good if if former president Trump is
convicted in a court of law would you
still support him as your party's Choice
please raise your hand if you would
look at this door
[Applause]
former president Trump the body language
there is such a loser the fact that he's
looking around coward and like the
little shoulder twitch just like all of
it every part of that would you still
support him as your party's Choice
please raise your hand if you would
um
[Applause]
in a court of law would you still
support him as so there it is you know
what I mean uh
uh oh and finally uh Vivek am I saying
his name right you've said it different
device I gave up I just say Vivek I know
it's like supposed to be Viv ache yes oh
Vivek yeah like cake okay I can okay now
I know yeah
but that's wow oddly specific sack so
here is Vivek he's ready for revolution
baby and he went over Tim pull on this
one for sure Civil War let's go
as long as you're on the front line
brother do you want a Super PAC puppet
or do you want a patriot who speaks the
truth do you want
or do you want Revolution okay and I
stand outside of the American Revolution
no more incremental change damn it
we need War
that's what the I'm talking about
Vivek yeah he he also has really fun
ideas like uh uh doing it like a like a
Civic uh test
like a Civics test to be able to vote
between the ages of like 18 to 24 or
something yeah which is wild uh wow
really it's really stupid just
Service uh and he also guarantees set it
up and he claimed that the sorry he
it up he his own personal
Civics test by uh claiming that the the
Constitution is the reason why the
American Revolution succeeded when the
Constitution came much later yeah
decades later hmm oops well meanwhile
back at the ranch as they say Trump
refused to participate in the debate
however he uh rendezvoused with his
bestie disgraced uh Tucker Carlson yeah
for some exclusive counter programming
that took place at the exact same time
as the debate
um
so
let's take a look at that
let's see he had some he had some spicy
debate takes
uh live tweeting Ada was a joke tonight
he's over
Chris Christie was horrible tonight he
was booed at a level never seen before
he's not wrong
I never
I never asked Mike Pence to put me above
the Constitution who would say such a
thing a fake story
this the sanctimonious was a bomb
tonight especially with the softball
interview with Sean Hannity this guy's a
total forgotten his past who cares
he's right he's right
um what is g date wait what the is
D Donald Trump BJT Donald J that's his
initials he's tweeting from his dad's
account what no no no Donald John Trump
is the is he's signing his tweets he's
signing off on his tweets okay he signed
his tweets since when does he do that I
don't know yeah that is kind of weird
this isn't actually so this is a account
that reposts his truth social oh
Twitter which is very helpful shout out
to whoever runs up that's actually
iconic ghoul that runs that yeah
probably but still thank you for making
me not have to go to truth
uh Ron Des sanctimonious is always
talking about the number of votes he got
in Florida he doesn't say that I got a
record 1.1 million more votes than him
he forgot
so okay he couldn't help himself but
let's take a look at the interview
um here's one Tucker asks Trump who he
thinks shouldn't be on the debate stage
um
interesting
who when you say there are people on
stage you shouldn't be running for
president who do you mean
his name but it wouldn't matter too much
a guy like uh I call him Ada Hutchinson
that's the crazy face freak yeah so wait
why does he call him Ada well let's see
just let's see okay okay okay I feel you
competition
when you say there are people on stage
you shouldn't be running for president
who do you mean
there's names but it wouldn't but I
wouldn't I like
like Hutchinson it's ASAP but I call him
Ada uh you know I could tell you but I
don't want to
get myself in a little trouble but he's
weak and professional what does he mean
like you think it's a American
Disabilities Act or something that was
what uh Zach speculated earlier we were
talking about it before the show how
does Ada mean as a it's like Ada
no I think he's saying he looks like a
woman or something I think that's
literally his joke
Ada maybe I mean like is that a woman
isn't that a woman's name I mean that is
a much simpler joke so I think you're
you might be right yeah because like I
don't think he knows what the the
American Disabilities Act is you know
what I mean no no no he wasn't
referencing that
because he's not even like disabled he's
fine he's just he's got a soft looking
face he's got a baby face dare I say he
might even say he might be saying that
he looks trans maybe which is more
horrible but that might be what he's
thinking I think he's saying I like the
woman thing I think he's saying he's
like secretly a woman which is yeah I
mean that's that's why they say that
they say Michelle Obama strands in a
similar way like it's just
that's what that is his name would be a
girl because he's a girl he looks like a
girl he looks like such a demon dude I
don't know what the it is he just
scares the out of me yeah I can see
it man he really
he stuck with me and he didn't talk a
lot but he really stood out to me as a
as a as a uniquely terrifying yeah so
he's the only other guy other than Chris
Christie who's there to be like I'm the
anti-trump guy
which you know there's not a lot of
interest
who would have thought that there's not
a lot of interest from the Republican
cult
uh for any kind of anti-trump sentiment
shocking
uh
I am gonna pull up another clip here
from the you should actually just you
should just play the very beginning of
the interview there's a moment right at
the first like beat of this video that
is so odd
sure I'll open that up let's take a look
it's debating
uh
uh okay you could clean that wasn't that
so like yeah you could why did they just
leave that like that just clean that up
a little bit they look hot but we're not
in Milwaukee
okay what just let it roll don't
just let it roll just just just just
feel it out Mr President I found that
song it's debate night but we're not in
Milwaukee
no we aren't
good
well said cool
uh Trump went on a really bizarre
tangent about the Panama Canal which was
pretty cool oh he was awesome the one
about the mosquitoes yeah Panama Canal
it was 35 000. I love where his mind's
at nobody's thinking about the Panama
Canal he's so good he's so good he's so
good this is such a classic this is such
a classic Trump Moment Like Old School
Trump bit right here on fire
okay nobody's thinking about Panama
Canal why why aren't they realism in our
hemisphere well yeah and it's far beyond
Cuba it's all over South America yeah in
the Caribbean so we built a thing called
the Panama Canal with almost 35 000
people to the mosquito you know malaria
yeah we lost 35 000 people building we
lost 35
000 people because of the mosquito
delicious they had a bad word that party
that's a sound bite we those
five thousand people to the mosquito and
I ask is that true no uh the official
number is like around 5 000 I think and
it's mostly
um
I had no reason to doubt that to be
honest because malaria did kill a
shitload of people so that's even
funnier here's what happened here's what
happened how many Dan okay it's uh I
think it's like 5 800 or something is
the official number however uh people
estimate that it's much much higher than
that except it wasn't Americans that
died it was like I think the
official number of American deaths to uh
uh during the construction was like 500
which is still a lot
uh it was mostly like the local native
people that were there right
one one American dying is too much okay
so I see a high figure of 25
000 and that's a higher figure and
that's so that's still not 30. what do
you say 35 000 I think he said yeah
whatever whatever okay a lot of people
died
yeah that's it was 35
000 true great
wonders of the world as he said one of
the nine wonders of the world who said
nine wonders who's he I don't know who
he's talking about whoever he's talking
about doesn't know how many people this
is my favorite part no no here it really
corrects himself don't worry yes you're
right you're the correct himself who
corrects this fictional person that he
just made up who said it yeah him yeah
he didn't it was one of the seven this
happened hold on let me go back
sweetie it was seven but he's so smart I
was one of the seven it was right and
the way his body language one of the
true great
wonders of the world as he said one of
the nine Wonders of the World no no it
was one of the seven this happened a
little while ago you know what
is he Lucid right now
well you could make nine wonders he
would have been better off of me a
little while ago you know and wondered
if Tucker is like the what was that
Tucker's like this is gold this is
content gold thank you sir since nine
wonders of the world you could make nine
wonders he would have been better off if
he stuck with a nine and just said yeah
I think it's nice but the what I have no
dude it's awesome let me try to on
untangle this
so he says there's a guy yeah he says
there's nine wonders there's only seven
no no Trump corrects him yeah not now
you'd be better off if you just left it
at nine yeah
he says like you no no I think he says
you could technically build two more
wonders no okay and make it nine wonders
of the world but it got it
two more wonders like a Trump Tower
that's like Taj Mahal but Trump Taj
Mahal Trump Mahal they're calling it
they're saying it's the ninth and tenth
Wonder
this is one of the true seven wonders of
the world and you take a look at the
Panama Canal it was such such an
incredible engineering yes Marvel I
don't think it is by the way
even of like the seven wonders of like
the modern world there's there's like a
million like ways they classify that but
well there is a very specific number of
Seven Wonders they're like these are
specific places well there's the seven
like Ancient Wonders which are well
established but then you know there's
more like modern ones that aren't so
eurocentric Coliseum have like Great
Wall I know yeah there you go I was just
I was just looking about who said the
nine Wonder Joe Biden said it oh
that's actually brilliant he's just he
just missed this Market he's working at
too high a level for us interesting that
iconic what a genius apparently Biden
called uh the Grand Canyon the ninth
wonder of the world
oh but some people say that like as an
expression or no they say because like
it's the one extra ninth not so much
yeah nine nine not Christ the Redeemer
Machu Picchu Peru uh
uh
the Pyramids in Mexico Petra some of
these wonders are mid
well I have to say yeah the best pyramid
that's a Wonder nobody's calling it a
Wonder folks
have you guys seen this pyramid we built
it it's beautiful
got three sides what just because no
aliens built it doesn't mean it's a
wonder it's wonderful the aliens built
it
who a human couldn't build it it's
fantastic we sold it to Panama for one
dollar
the following day I love The Grieving
still the Panama Canal was sold for one
dollar what a bad he's so mad what a bad
deal if only we could go back either
quadrupled
the amount of money the chips had to pay
to get across they didn't lose one ship
and now they've made it much bigger and
now they've widen it they've doubled it
right they've more than doubled it
and it's one of the most profitable
things any time it it's it's just
incredible right we gave it away for one
dollar
China Now controls it they actually
control the Panama Canal they run it
they control it and we shouldn't let
that happen and we can't get it back
again
controls most of International Shipping
but not in the way that he thinks they
do
um they control it by way of the
containers the containers that you have
in an allotment like that is being
utilized a big chunk of them are owned I
Believe by uh I Believe by China
so like
any kind of logistical hurdle uh or
whenever there's any kind of logistical
bottleneck it's actually the the
shipping containers uh that uh the
Chinese owned that uh can cause
instability but China does not own the
Panama Canal I'm assuming no I think
he's just talking about how like uh you
know China has made a lot of efforts in
in
um he's right though we need to get the
canal back we built that yeah for
one dollar one dollar 35
000 people died of that man
it's the most valuable thing I ever
built
is it possible that like a Chinese firm
like runs operations like has been
contracted to run operations in Panama
Canal I'd be surprised but yeah you
could certainly look it up
all right and finally uh Tucker has a
question about Trump's good friend
Jeffrey Epstein oh yeah I feel but it
was just interesting I read bars
account of his time he wrote a book
about it right uh his autobiography and
in it he lies about Jeffrey Epstein's
death clearly lies yeah
do you do you think Epstein killed
himself sincerely
I don't you as a close and personal
Confidant friend of his you would know
yeah do you think he killed himself is
he that type of guy he is a banger
answer I don't know I I will say that
you know he was a fixture in Palm Beach
yeah he was a fiction why wouldn't you
say that that part is insane I knew him
well why would you I think what
he's trying to say is like my
association with him was par for the
course of residence there we all knew
him I was no different than the rep no I
think he's gonna say the classic like
when I knew he was weird and gross I
like kicked him out or something we were
good friends at Palm Beach she was like
well frequently went with G Lane
beautiful lady beautiful lady because
like uh other like there's a lot of
people that definitely kept up
appearances with Jeffrey Epstein long
after he was arrested Trump was not one
of them if we're being real okay even
though even though Jeffrey Epstein did
use
Donald Trump's very own Mar-A-Lago White
House of the White House of the South as
they call it uh is a is a hunting ground
okay yeah interesting
he recruited or like basically picked up
uh uh Virginia Jeffrey I think from
Mar-A-Lago fantastic the women here are
the best and more importantly they know
more importantly or or more the more
interesting connection between Jeffrey
Epstein and Donald Trump is not the
direct one it's the indirect one
Alexander Acosta was the uh Hotshot
prosecutor
that actually gave the insane sweetheart
plea bargain deal to Jeffrey Epstein
when uh uh the first time around when
Jeffrey Epstein was arrested and was uh
being criminally charged with sex
trafficking minors and that sweetheart
plea bargain uh was not dissimilar to
the hunter Biden uh plea bargain here
I'll use a term that Republicans are
familiar with where there was an active
federal case
uh that was ongoing which uh Jeffrey
Epstein was and and his known associates
were completely uh like they they were
taken out of that federal case due to
some of the terms and conditions in this
uh in this plea bargain deal that
Jeffrey Epstein got uh for uh for
pleading guilty to uh sex trafficking
minors in a much lighter uh sentence
right I think they allowed him to plead
guilty to just prostitution right yeah
which is interesting way like less
charge because right and that's true
yeah he did prostitution but the fact
that they were kids is a minor detail so
so here's what's really interesting
about that
Alexander Acosta that seems like a like
a famous name boy do I know that oh
that's right Trump made him his labor
secretary so I love labor that is a that
is a very interesting connection there's
a more interesting Connection in my
opinion yeah
uh fantastic
uh I don't know what Barr said about it
either I have no idea what he said what
did he say he killed himself probably he
said he killed himself and that they
were going to do this investigation they
never did the investigation it's never
been public and they hit it and like why
are they doing that they clearly Barn
knew but why would Bill Barr how is this
one of your questions like gross also
why are they talking about it like Bill
Barr isn't Trump's guy like the whole
thing is weird well he's not Bill Barr
went after uh Bill Barr decided he's no
longer Trump I know and now he isn't but
like the door's closed right
but to the outside yeah yeah I I closed
it but I hope they didn't leave it open
Sky will run outside
100 Jesus but still yeah it's not a good
idea she is an explorer
I'll be covering up the death of Jeffrey
Epstein Bill Barr didn't do an
investigation on the election fraud
either okay he said he did he did but he
didn't uh that McSwain the U.S attorney
in Pennsylvania Philadelphia uh said bar
just wouldn't let him do it it was crazy
bar
he probably doesn't come back to the
Epstein thing I'm imagining
I think that's it yeah yeah uh so that's
basically it for our for us for what we
have here today
one final no I'll leave on uh might take
on the Trump thing
is that I think it was a major L for him
not to participate in the debate I've
been a long-standing firm Donald Trump
supporter as everybody knows I think he
thrives in the debate environment the
notion that he was like 50 points ahead
70 points ahead in certain polls does
not change that reality that like you
think it's bad for a poll likewise
I think that it was bad that he did not
participate in this debate and I think
that there was a different reason as to
why he didn't participate in the debate
than the one that he is presenting like
oh I'm just too far ahead why would I
give them clout why do I say this
because Donald Trump is so good at you
know ritualistically humiliating his
interlocutors in a televised debate he
is infinitely more charismatic he's way
way more quick-witted than everybody
else on that stage
um he would have made mincemean out of
them like he did in the original
Republican primaries so
um I think that uh the there's two
different uh there's two different
speculations on this one is from my
friend Felix biederman of Choppa Trap
House who believes that they're trying
to do the basement strategy with Joe
Brandon but for Donald Trump because
he's already trailing so there's no
reason to like really unleash him into
the public I don't fully agree with that
um I think that he thrives when he's in
public unlike Rhonda santis who keeps
dipping in his poll numbers every time
he speaks uh Donald Trump has the
opposite effect
and he needs that audience more than
anything else and he thrives in a debate
stage he would have shown the real uh
reasons as to why people love him on
that debate stage he would have made a
mockery of everyone there
um I think that the real reason this is
my speculation was that he needed to ask
permission from the federal courts to be
able to appear on stage because well
because Mike Pence is a star Witness
star witness in uh in in at least one of
his four definitely like do some
intimidation well yeah probably what
he's still Tweeting about him but I
think appearing side by side in person
alongside the key witness in uh his
active court case would have required
him to possibly ask for permission from
the federal courts that's a great and I
think instead of coming across as weak
asking for permission and possibly even
getting refused yeah uh permission he
decided to avoid it all together
um we'll see we'll see if he comes out
uh on the second one uh because he's
definitely gonna show up to other
debates there's no way like he has to he
was live tweeting that thing
like you know he wanted to be there I
know he wanted to be there I hope that's
not the case because I really really
want to see Trump on this yeah these
Federal these federal circuit judges
like need to have more content brain I
don't really appreciate the way that
they're operating go on but here is
actually the roster uh back
that's awesome yeah
awesome well done and I guess in this
case Batman would be
Donald Trump
billionaire billionaire bad boy saving
Gotham dude more like karma karma wait
he's the he's the it's gonna be Joker
isn't here Trump's Joker yeah oh yeah
yeah he is the most Joker fied yeah is
Joe Biden Batman I guess in this analogy
though yeah yeah he doesn't feel like a
good Batman though
yeah yeah I don't know I don't know
all right guys listen it's been a swell
time Hassan thank you for being here
we made it happen you know what I mean
we don't give a it's a public
service it's important that the people
they have to hear this
you know and then great well you know
what's going to happen next is David
from PMP is going to come free all these
guys get Gotham City back stocked up
again with villains
um they wish they could get a lawyer
that good true they can't afford it all
right Hassan anything else nope that'll
be all for me I'm gonna go and get ready
for the Trump mug shot slash uh more
analysis on my stream that's exciting
man yeah big day big day for me but just
put in your what do you think his
expression is going to be
what do I think his expression is going
to be yeah I think he's going to try to
hit a blue steel
like a
like a not
like resentful but not uh
maybe that or smiling but I think I
think it'll probably be like frustrated
I think a smile might be the best move
because if he goes straight face he's
gonna risk looking like one of these
freaks yeah I agree that guy like a
really joyous smile
like a big beautiful smile from my big
beautiful president I think that is
nothing wrong he did everything right
and they indicted him but I'm sure that
they've had a great long discussion
about what he should do with his facial
expression so I'm very curious to see
how that plays out well guys thanks for
watching
I appreciate y'all being here tomorrow's
stream is going to be better tomorrow
stream will be better thank you for for
letting everyone know yeah this one was
even though we had so much good stuff to
talk about it was not good I thought it
was good I you keep saying that I've
moved past that I always I always think
it's good I thought it was like a fun
episode we had a yeah we we we had to
overcome trials and tribulations to to
come here to make this so yeah there was
you know shouts out to Dan and love
shouts out
yeah I appreciate that guys and uh so
we'll be here tomorrow as usual
and golly
um golly maybe we'll see at the Streamys
maybe not
I think depends if somebody gets sick
I'm there I'm there to run defense for
you if because xuc is supposed to be
there too right just pull up on you I'm
there thank you bro the person I'm
really
um
really hate there
uh is a Shetty uh what's this
guy Jay Shetty J Shetty yeah that guy no
nobody does who is that guy it's the guy
who wins every award for no reason he's
got beautiful wait is that the the sexy
brown guy yeah with like the piercing
eyes yeah dude his eyes for no reason
because I'm like a brown-eyed Normie or
something but like sometimes when I see
eyes like that I'm like what's dude stop
staring at me like what's going on are
you lasering me oh God yeah this
is his beautiful eyes wait did he
actually hang out with Jeffrey Epstein
what are you talking about I just want
to show his beautiful eyes wait is that
real huh I don't know I just typed I
just typed uh chat is it real I yes time
is this real concerning I just typed his
name and I just just to show you his
eyes dude stop stop zooming it's just
like he's piercing into my soul dude
he's he
it's like he's got x-ray vision they
both have beautiful eyes kind of I'm not
not as beautiful though no no those are
special kind of not as beautiful
um no I don't know anything about that
guy except for the fact that he's like
he's like hot in a in a scary way like
it just he
his eyes they scare me yeah Jay Shetty
he's gonna win podcast of the year he's
going to win creator of the year he's
gonna do a total sweep wait would it
really who the what yeah in the
world is this one of those podcasts that
like I I suspect what is it like
holistic self-help and he gets like
Barack Obama or some on the podcast
a few weeks ago and nobody watched that
it got like 300 000 views it's like
it's like one of those where it's like
who the set this up like what do
you got what kind of Bookers you got man
who are you working with the Illuminati
does is um the uh
the Darman type of weird pseudo Darman
used to be my goat until the labor
disputes man uh just you hate to see a
you hate to see a player fall from the
top like that well you know
um
Darman uh was a
was a uh
he was a criminal did you know that yeah
I did know and back in I think it was
Berkeley or San Francisco yeah was it
was it I think it was Weed really no no
no
yeah yeah real estate fraud love that
love that for him defrauded the
government somehow with like grants yeah
oh I'm sorry I didn't realize that was
illegal that sounds actually that sounds
similar to what Pearl said her dad was
doing
uh could be
um Dar man and Jay Shetty by the way
have a show together I know they do the
two goats and they're both in the
thumbnail the DAR and Jay show so uh
Darman also very why are they both
holding themselves they're because
they're sexy hot dude they're
hard
they're hot man's got that like
that that like haircut that absolutely
he no one his age should have
you know he's just great
thought his content is like I said his
content was the greatest but he did
wrong by his employees and I don't I
don't stand for that I think it's
up phone's still shut
up telling you he's gonna win he's gonna
win can't beat are you nominated for
what for like three things I don't know
exactly what you lose to shitty uh I'm
in the I think I'm in the news category
just chatting streamer maybe streamer of
the Year probably usually those are the
three categories that people put me out
for uh not sure if I'll win this year
but hey you know
we're gonna go out there and and uh
leave it all on the field yeah
we're gonna win podcasts this year
good luck doubt do you when you win do I
technically win as well because
leftovers I don't think so oh yeah he
does he definitely did you say I don't
think so he's like no I don't
guy dude five percent is everything what
do you mean I win five percent of that
you're nominated for three events just
enjoy your own four because technically
best podcast best podcast thank you Dan
you got it man yeah no I think it's more
about us than you oh wow that's that's
crazy I was like should Hassan come up
on stage with us if we win I'm 100
coming up these days I'll be like not
you no I'm running up there I'm rushing
into this thing I love you so much for
this award for me yeah you'll accept the
award yeah
all right guys
um now you have to be there because if
you win and you're not there I'm taking
that award that if I'm not there and we
will please you can go up and now I'm
gonna be like I thought you were gonna
finally motivate him to want to go with
that but yeah I really thought reverse
psychology
nothing's worse than that
um guys we'll see you tomorrow thank you
everybody thank you Hassan thank you to
all of our wonderful uh Republicans out
there debating their hearts putting it
all on the line
you guys have a great day see you next
time
foreign
[Music]